[Applause]
you will see real blood
[Music]
the fights are very intensive rough and
tough so real they can go really dark
which is great it's incredibly wrong
rubble barking
[Music]
it was true pleasure to just get to dive
in headfirst
my father is one of the first Taekwondo
masters to come to the United States and
I competed for most of my life
jujitsu wrestling judo Filipino life
techniques Corrections frightening when
he fights I think Joel sells out very
well so the null g sequence was about
grabbing the other person and slamming
them into your fists I'd loved it
I had a lot of fun I think we're hit
Martha she has such spunk and fire to
her she goes all out with everything
we're always you know in constant
training for all these fights it's been
really incredible sometimes it's been
like 2 or 3 hours a day and I go and I
train you gotta keep going no matter
what she would not stay down she kept
getting back up so when you see that
action you're seeing the actors you're
fighting and you know the choreography
and for me as an actress it's empowering
productive conversation
[Music]
your body is not who you are
you shed it like a snake sheds of skin
we transfer the human consciousness
between bodies
to live fraternal life I will live up
and down 250 years
you are the property the Bancroft
industries you've been provided with
this body which came equipped with
military-grade Nurik em and combat
muscle memory
mr. Cole - I didn't ask you to bring me
back into this world what I ask of you
is that you solve a murder whose name
this is the beginning
whoever murdered him must be found we're
all in danger you need access that you
don't want to do and I'm gonna find
answers they always thank you
[Music]
friends enemies people with opportunity
and motive just anybody
if you don't solve this quickly enough I
thought you'd be bigger
they made me bring all this back it's
rude
here's more here than know we like to
see
mr. e needs to be solved
[Music]
and lieutenant you know saving your ass
is not my only job I like her this is
the beginning
you